...............
I have a lot of haters
i have a lot of haters
hi
*close up*
enemies
Dylan the Hacker
Leafy (senpai)
Keemstar
They are all out to
They're all out to destroy me!
Destroy Me!!!!!!!!!
But there is one
Dare I ever say it
Man
Who is stronger
than all of these combined
His name is
Malcolm (daddy)
fourteen
sixty
six *Malcolm1466
*How's it going bro*
*my name is*
*brah*
Why does he hate me
I hate Pew Dee Pie!
But he is filled with more hatred than
Hitler was for the Jews™
*Pew Dee Pie*
*Working*
*for the*
*money*
He is filled with more hatred than
Keemstar is
to unbiased news reporting
*high pitched voice you're not going to care about*
Now I'm at the point
where I don't know what to do anymore
But it seems like
He disappeared *GASP
Malcolm
where are you?
I have searched the internet
for an answer
from the farthest east
to the northest west
Malcolm's videos are nowhere to be found
Why is this
WHY
NEED
ANSWERS
WHERE IS HE
WHEEEREEE IIISSSS HEEEEEEEE?!?!?!?!?
What is this
A shed of hope?
the truth about
Malcolm1466
DJ Vailoc...DJ Vailoc
Dj
Vialock?
DJ
Vailoc
The reasons to hate Pewdiepie
*The reasons why I hate Pew-*
*barf noise*
What the fuck happened?
*The reasons why I hate Pew-*
OH MY GOD!
You are no Malcolm
You sound different
You sound different...  You look different... Is he wearing his skin? (puberty, thats what happened)
You look different
Is he wearing his skin?
*more barf noise*
one
Malcolm: One. He's always on my repture (what is a repture page) page.
*He's always on my repture? page*
I'm always on his what page?
*that laugh* hetetetetteetetetet
*on my webture? page*
Well if I'm always on your recommended page
maybe that's because you watched my videos
Malcolm: When i open youtube, I see pewdipie, the stupid bitch
*inaudible*
*I think Pimp Di Pie*
*the stupid bitch*
Don't call me a bitch because
Dont call me a bitch cuz your a bitch too
you're a bitch too
Bitch (dat burn, maclom needs some ice)
Bitch!
*laugh*
*two*
two, number 2
*His fans*
*his fans are so ridiculous*
*what can I say*
*mhm... falcon Lower?*
*for example*
He knows about the Pewdiepie references!
Malcolm
You Love me. Say it!
You watch my videos
You know my references
What else is there?
Stop pretending
*dude*
*I have more stache*
*but you don't give a FUCK*
Did he just say?
DID HE?
*laughs*
Thank you
Did he just say
He has more stache
And he doesn't give a fuck
*claps*
It's been great
Thank you
Malcolm wins, Malcolm wins.
*I have more stache!!!*
That is a fucking nice stache
for an eight year old (BURNNNNNNNNNN)
*the most important part*
The most important part, here it comes
Okay
*Pewdiepie is Gay©*
*Copyright music©*
OH!
OH NO!
*Pewdiepie is gay©*
*barf noises*
I can't
*The real piggy pew the pig*
*Pewdiepig is a fucking p-*  *ENDS video
What am I
What am I?
You can't just exit the video right there
What Am I?
Pewdie What?
I Don't Know
Wait, what the fuck is this?
*errrrrr...*
Alfa Romeo Greenbox concept
Why am I watching this?
OH MY GOD!!!
IT'S MALCOLM! (pewds is happy)
*look at that face*
But Malcolm you are too young to drive
Go Malcolm! ( I SHIP)
GO!
Wow
He's right, he is much cooler
Yeah!!
Malcolm!
Oh what is he doing
*speechless*
How is Malcolm in an Alfa Romeo commercial
And I'm not...
*sad music*
Malcolm
Or
DJ Vailoc
Or whatever your name is
I'm gonna send you a message
check it out
I'm calling you
check out the message
and reply
Alright guys
We have a lot of fun with Malcolm
A lot of fun
I don't want it to be too far
I don't want anyone to go and harass this kid
I don't want anyone
who happen to find his identity
to do anything, to even look for it alright
We made up the name Malcolm
because we don't want people to find his identity
And we didn't want people to harassing him
I just think his video is hysterical
I think he has a funny personality
and I would love to have him featured on my channel
Malcolm, DJ Vailoc
I've been trying to reach you
I'm gonna write you a message on YouTube, Twitter
Check your Facebook
I'll find you everywhere alright
I would love to have you on the PewDiePie channel
I get it if you are not interested
And to all my Bros
Don't harass this guy
It's not cool
I'm never into that
I just react to the videos
If I see anyone of you harassing, bullying, whatever
You're out, alright
That's it for this video
If you enjoy watching, please leave a like
Thank you so much
Hopefully we can get DJ Vailoc
Or Malcolm, his real name is Malcolm
On the PewDiePie channel
I will love to fly him over to UK
I don't know
That's all for me for now, and as always
Stay awesome Bros ¯\_(ツ)_/¯